all right it's week five show me
something draft time peter i've got a
trivia question for you are you ready
i'm ready
kyle allen will be the 30th different
starting quarterback for the washington
franchise since 1993.
name the two teams who have had more
than 30 starting quarterbacks since
1993.
that's amazing that is i'm amazed that
that there have been two teams
um i am going to say
uh
jacksonville in the new york jets
oh
i thought you'd get cleveland i thought
cleveland would be easy because of that
mannequin that had the children the
reason why i eliminated cleveland is
that they were good they didn't play for
four years
even it making makes that even more
amazing that they're number one chicago
with 32 as they continue to look for
their next franchise quarterback maybe
they have one in nick foles maybe nick
foles is finally the guy who picks up
the torch of jim mcmahon or arguably sid
luckman all right show me something
draft plenty to choose from this weekend
i'm going to start
with our sunday night game look it's
prime time it's going to be dark in
seattle we know kirk cousins history
playing under the lights he gets a break
this time around though seems like they
go to seattle every year like they're in
the same division or something they're
back again mike zimmer's never beaten
seattle kirk cousins is going to a place
where they just get smothered every year
this year it could be different this
year it's going to be a shootout i think
this year the offense has a chance to
score some points now look the vikings
may get outscored by the seattle
seahawks but there's no excuse for kirk
cousins to not have a big game against a
porous seattle defense with no fans
there to set the richter scale rocking
you know all throughout greater seattle
so
if kirk cousins is ever
going to reverse the prime time
narrative against a good team he kind of
reversed it last year against the
cowboys but they weren't very good the
seahawks are undefeated this is his
chance to prove to everyone that he can
step up in a big spot at night and get
it done peter
for minnesota i have a chance to win
this game mike in my opinion adam
thielen's got to have a 150 yard
receiving day because he's going to be
playing a suspect secondary with corners
you can throw on and if
uh kirk cousins doesn't take advantage
of the matchups
that uh you know that adam thielen will
present against the seattle secondary i
don't think they've got a chance to win
all right you're up what do you got
well here would be my biggest question
about sort of this weekend of football
mike
here's and here it is
so
the cleveland browns are what
i mean i i'm just i'm totally fascinated
by the cleveland browns what are they
and how good are they
yeah and i think you know i give i give
sims a hard time for picking an entire
team but i can't fault you for that
because this is a total team effort and
an opportunity
to push back against an early season
narrative that the cults are pretty damn
good this is the browns chance to step
up both this week and next week and show
what they have all right next one for me
jj watt to the extent that there was a
feud with bill o'brien and jj watt wins
and bill o'brien's out and there were
reports suggesting that you know bill
o'brien who
yeah he got in verbal altercations with
people the final weeks on the job we
always got verbal altercations with
people but apparently it finally reached
critical mass j.j watt reportedly at the
center of it jj you got what you wanted
now it's time to step up and do
something with that defense against the
jacksonville team that that should be
a team they should they can handle and
limit in scoring enough that they can
win the game so i want to see what jj
watt and the rest of the texans defense
can do this weekend peter in the first
game without bill o'brien since he was
hired seven years ago
i almost want to say jack easterby what
do you got but that's a little bit too
inside baseball or inside football right
now so i'm going to give you this one
this is the one that i'm
you know after the browns this weekend
i'm most curious about what do you got
daniel jones
okay
seven turnovers in four games you have
not scored 17 points yet i understand
your offensive line stinks but in the
span of one month you not only have put
dave gettleman absolutely unequivocally
on borrowed time but in addition
you may be starting to put yourself on
borrowed time and again it's way too
early to suggest that daniel jones might
not be the quarterback long term but
this is a year he's got to grow this is
a year he's got to develop he's not
cured his turnover bug and he's not done
anything to lift a bad offense
and great players lift bad units he did
that last year when he took over his
quarterback for eli manning he's not
doing it this year that simply must
change mike
hey peter the clock round out on dwayne
haskins in washington with a new
coaching staff the clock could run out
on daniel jones in new york with a new
coaching staff as well next one for me
and i'm going to do this because you
went with the entire browns organization
i'm going to go with the entire titans
organization show me something or more
accurately show me nothing show me no
new positive tests over the course of
the next few days show me that you've
gotten this outbreak under control and
show me that you're going to comply with
all protocols and requirements going
forward it really is stunning that any
nfl team has gotten itself into such a
mess and the more we hear about it we
talked about it earlier in the show
it's mind-boggling that they've
jeopardized their season and that peter
i think that there may be i don't know
this could be a late afternoon friday
news dump coming with news is what the
nfl is going to do to the titans but uh
show me that you can actually get a game
in because if this weekend's game goes
away as well
uh i don't know what the hell they're
gonna do
show me something roger goodell
and
what i mean by this is when you issue
you issue your sanction against the
tennessee titans
make it not only hurt the tennessee
titans
but
shine a very bright light on all other
the other 31 teams in the nfl and say to
each one of them you think this was bad
if your team screws up like this
i'm going to make it worse i'm going to
make it hurt and i'm going to start
involving forfeits
yeah i still don't know what they're
going to do about forfeits peter there's
an there's an issue out there
as to whether or not the players would
get paid in the event of forfeits
because the nflpa has only agreed that
players don't get paid for games that
are cancelled or suspended a forfeit
technically counts as a game
the the final score of a forfeited game
is two nothing and it goes into the
standings i think the nfl is going to
use forfeit as the absolute last resort
if they think they have to pay the
players
yeah it to me
this is more important than that
you know and if it's going to cost a
team some some money especially a team
that that has to forfeit and
particularly
the team that gets disadvantaged by the
forfeit now we have to decide how that
team is going to get paid
well maybe the team that caused the
forfeit pays the salary that week of the
team that didn't cause the forfeit that
would be another deterrent we'll see how
it all plays out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports